manifestation de gens en faveur et en
défaveur du projet frontières en alberta
c'était le 22 janvier devant les locaux
de textos reçus ce dakar est le premier
ministre de l'alberta jason kenney
presse justin trudeau d'approuver
rapidement ce projet de mine au nord de
fort mcmurray
on vous explique ce soir l'importance de
ce projet frontière avec nous eric
pineau professeur à l'institut des
sciences de l'environnement de l'uqam
ont soir eric pinon bonsoir projet très
important 20 milliards de dollars ce
serait le plus gros projet de sables
bitumineux de l'histoire c'est le plus
gros est fait en termes de capacité de
production des plus importants aussi au
pic de production prévoit être 260000
baril par jour donc c'est majeur comme
comme projet en termes de superficie ses
massifs ccc le projet ses 242 kilomètres
carrés et donc ses écrans à peu près de
l'île jésus ou de la ville de laval
entendent allouer superficie ses deux
mines à ciel ouvert qui recouvre à peu
près cette superficie et entre les deux
un complexe de raffinage de 2,2 et de
transport après ça de s'habituer à de la
ressource en photo et donc c'est
vraiment donc au nord de fort mcmurray
quel type d'extraction p500 classique
avec donc on tasse tout ce qui est en
surface
on enlève les premiers mètres de sol et
après on pelt on met dans des camions
bennes et on amène dans un complexe de
raffinage donc ces essais le dernier
projet de ce type c'est à dire que c'est
le dernier gisement qui est à 100
surface pour qu'on puisse l'exploiter de
manière classique le comme on voit sur
l'image avec ce type d'extraction et
avec ce type de paysage qui en résultent
aussi oui et donc on pourrait exploiter
cet endroit pendant quoi 41 années on
prévoit mettre en service la mine si
tout ce passe mais mais bon c'est pas
certain que ça se passe comme prévu mais
en 2026 on mettre en service la mine et
on prévoit aller pour 41 1
ce qui nous amène en 2020 en 2000 26 27
tous les pendants 2006 pour commencer et
jusqu'à 2002 soit 160 wii 2 866 à 1067
et donc ça nous met très loin dans le
21e siècle ça nous amène très loin après
cette date butoir des accords de paris
oui où on devrait avoir réduit nos grc
c'est un des enjeux majeurs de cette
mine c'est sa contribution qui est
massive
sa contribution est importante mais
pourtant il ya eu un rapport fédéral
provincial qui avait publié l'automne
dernier qui disaient oui ce sera
émetteur de gaz à effet de serre mais si
dans l'intérêt public quand exactement
donc pour le moment le processus
d'approbation est positif toutes les
agences qui ont travaillé sur le projet
d'un feu vert parce que quand on balance
du point de vue de l'économie albertaine
et l'économie canadienne l'emploi les
retombées et l'impact environnemental et
bien on trouve que les retombées
économiques en valent la chandelle par
contre le rapport dont paris précise que
la question de l'atteinte des objectifs
de paris est à l'extérieur du périmètre
d'analysé du rapport et donc on ne tient
pas compte des objectifs des engagements
du canada
on tient jusqu'en des politiques en
place au moment où on fait l'analyse et
donc c'est ce fameux cas de 102 5
mégatonnes pour l'alberta pour le
secteur des sables bitumineux et on
reste en deçà de ce qu'avait donc
l'alberta sera l'intérieur de ces cibles
ces sites mais le canada on le sait pas
il ya trop d'incertitudes ce qu'on sait
c'est qu'on parle de 4 4 points 1 1
million de
g us de tonnes de ges par année donc
c'est majeur ce serait le complexe
industriel le plus grand en terme
d'émissions le plus grand émetteur de
ges au canada il donc la liberté est
d'accord avec ça je l'aï mines et c'est
d'accord oui et le gouvernement fédéral
doit se prononcer le doigt le grand de
fédérale 2 devant une décision c'est le
cabinet qui doit trancher à partir des
recommandations qu'il a reçu de ses
différents d'évaluation maintenant ce
qui est fait le plus je dirais
problématique mon projet c'est pas tant
la dimension environnementale qui est
très problématique mais mais ce qui
risque de faire en fait que le projet
voit le jour c'est la dimension
économique qu'antec donc texte une
compagnie minière s'est pas accompagnée
des sables bitumineux si elle est très
nouvelle dans le domaine entreprise de
vancouver entreprise de vancouver
surtout dans le cuivre en amérique du
sud
elle a une participation conjointe dans
le complexe sportif qui est un complexe
d'extraire extraction sables bitumineux
dans la région mais c'était un petit
essai maintenant elle se lance dans ces
grands projets quand elle fait si
prévisions 2015 elle dit mais le baril
en 2020 devrait être autour de 80 à 90
dollars
mais là on est autour de 50 mais voilà
et quand on met en service la mine donc
on comment s'extraire en 2010
on a besoin de 95 dollars ah oui ça
c'est en 2001 six aides en six ans si on
regarde l'évolution mondiale du marché
du pétrole
on vois pas de tendance si fortes à la
hausse pour les peaux des prochaines
années surtout avec l'incertitude
économique qui plane en asie qui est pas
juste rattacher la au cordeau virus mais
qui est beaucoup plus générale un
ralentissement qu'on voit depuis 18 mois
donc on pense que le prix sera pas au
rendez vous donc on se dit pour tech
c'est peut-être un projet option c'est à
dire qu on a l'option l'approbation nous
donne l'option de faire le projet mais
on va pas nécessairement se lancer de
l'avant pour faire le projet est en fait
je crois que c'est beaucoup plus un test
politique que l'alberta fait au fédéral
en disant est ce que votre décision sur
tech c'était une décision sont notés
instruits et notre province
beaucoup plus que sur ce projet là qui
reste de jamais voir le jour pour le
moment parce que les délits donne
économique son poteau grandi c'était
d'ailleurs la première question d'un
crochet parti conservateur en début de
semaine
à la chambre des communes en disant est
ce que vous allez à prouver ne pas
approuver donc la pression est mise sur
justin case aux vertus pour savoir s'ils
appuient le développement ou non
exactement du pétrole et c'est aussi un
projet qui en termes environnementaux a
des impacts non seulement pour les jets
à semer sur le milieu aussi c'est
tellement vaste qu'on projet est un
milieu très sensible c'est les
tourbières et des forêts qui ont jamais
été coupés et le canada s'apprête à
prendre des engagements fermes en termes
de respect de la biodiversité 30 % du
territoire devrait alors ça drôle en
compte aussi de cette volonté lors du
fédéral de dire regardez
en ce qui a trait à la biodiversité en
ce qui a trait à la protection des
milieux boréale
on veut aller de l'avant on veut être à
l'avant garde de ces de cet accord qui
s'en vient et là on est devant un projet
qui va complètement à l'encontre donc au
niveau des jeux s lumière rouge au
niveau de la biodiversité lumière rouge
puis au niveau de l'impact économique
beaucoup d'incertitudes parce que presse
que le projet au voir le jour et
deuxièmement en 2015 le degré
d'automatisation des opérations dans les
sables bitumineux uts est beaucoup moins
important tous les produits cas depuis
que le prix du pétrole a baissé ont
réduit leurs coûts en automatisant la
production entre autres les fameux
camion le convoi se promener sur les
images tantôt de plus en plus on tente
de les automatiser d'éliminer les
chauffeurs et donc l'impact en termes
d'emploi risquent d'être beaucoup moins
de russie puis si on va de l'avant à
60,10 mettons dollars le baril les
profits vont moins bien les impôts - gan
les redevances moindre on surveille ça
de près et éric pineault merci